[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
uns marietta slomka
abend immerhin über im akkord legt heute
nochmal nach seinen außenminister lässt
er verkünden der streit mit den usa
belaste auch die zukunft der nato
gestern abend hatte frankreich ja seinen
botschafter aus den usa und australien
vorübergehend zurückgerufen nach den
regeln der diplomatie ist das zwischen
demokratien der maximale wutausbruch
darüber hinaus blieben nur noch die
botschaft dann ganz abzuberufen oder gar
die diplomatischen beziehungen
abzubrechen das kommt zwischen ländern
die eigentlich verbündete sind stichwort
nato natürlich nicht in frage
dass frankreich so tobt liegt nicht nur
daran dass es sich um einen
milliarden-deal betrogen sieht sondern
auch an der kränkelnden erkenntnis dass
den amerikanern der machtkampf gegen
china wichtiger ist als europäische
befindlichkeiten christel haas berichtet
der mann in dem auto ist normalerweise
kein freund harte worte er ist
schließlich französischer botschafter in
australien doch jetzt macht er sich ganz
undiplomatisch luft über das verhalten
seines gastlandes
es ist ein großer fehler das ist ein
sehr sehr schlechter umgang mit unserer
partnerschaft
zurückbeordert nach paris wurde auch
sein kollege in den usa das ist einmalig
in der geschichte beider länder und
darum geht es die australier hatten vor
drei tagen einen seit jahren bestehenden
milliardenvertrag für zwölf französische
u boote aufgekündigt unmittelbar davor
hatten sie ein sicherheitsabkommen mit
den usa und großbritannien geschlossen
es geht um den schutz vor dem
machtstreben chinas im indopazifischen
raum statt französische soll australien
nun amerikanische und britische u boote
bekommen atom getrieben frankreich ist
plötzlich außen vor ein affront im
fernsehen wird der außenminister heute
mehr als deutlich in die höhe
hier geht es um lügen um doppel
zügigkeit um einen massiven
vertrauensbruch und um verachtung das
geht überhaupt nicht wir sind in einer
richtigen krise
vor allem die eigennützige haltung der
usa sei schier unerträglich
frankreich fühlt sich ins abseits
geschoben fürchtet um seinen einfluss es
ist eine diplomatische und
wirtschaftliche niederlage frankreichs
dieser vorfall zeigt einen
amerikanischen unilateralismus der
wirklich erstaunlich ist weil frankreich
eigentlich als einer der besten
verbündeten gilt
noch im juni hatten präsident makronen
der australische premier über die
zusammenarbeit und den hut vertrag
geredet über den neuen deal sei man aber
bis zuletzt nicht informiert worden
heißt es in paris gut in frankreich
irritation in der eu der
außenbeauftragte drängt zum handeln
diese situation zwingt uns nachzudenken
und zwar darüber ob wir nicht die idee
einer strategischen autonomie europas
die umsetzen müssen lucky stimmung
dohnanyi spd dickel europäer ein deal
und seine folgen die usa und australien
versuchen zu beschwichtigen frankreich
sei nach wie vor ein wichtiger partner
betonen beide länder den groll der
franzosen wird das nicht besänftigen
tja dann schalten wir noch zu at t sind
in washington immer wie wird das ganze
denn auf der anderen seite des atlantiks
gesehen
der die us regierung tut ein wenig
unschuldig sie verweist auf australien
hinter den kulissen die hätten ja
frankreich informieren müssen
tatsächlich hat der australische premier
morris und ja gesagt jetzt in einem
interview er habe präsident makro im
juni auf die massiven probleme mit dem
u-boot deal angesprochen auf die
massiven verzögerungen auf die viel zu
hohen kosten die sich nochmal gesteigert
hatten auch auf die veraltete
technologie und zitat morrison habe auch
gesagt ich habe klar gemacht dass
australien eine entscheidung treffen
muss in seinem nationalen interesse ich
glaube trotzdem dass der us regierung
ganz recht ist dass frankreich so lange
im dunkeln tappte weil man vielleicht
sowas wie ein signal ein schock
regelrecht aussenden wollte die usa
sehen nämlich die kommunistische führung
in peking als bedrohung während einige
nato pachter doch jedenfalls für beides
geschmack zu sehr auf beschwichtigung
scores mit der regierung in peking sein
und die usa sehen als belege für diese
bedrohungen an eben die ganzen
militärischen provokationen chinas in
den letzten monaten aber auch wie sehr
china mit druck mit
wirtschaftssanktionen auch mit drohungen
australien im vergangenen jahr unter
druck gesetzt hat und deswegen so
glauben die usa sollte australien auch
zur abschreckung atom u boote haben also
keine u boote mit veralteter technologie
die man schnell entdecken kann sondern
mit leisem atomantrieb deswegen wollte
man diesen deal unbedingt am liebsten
auch noch mit anderen mit indien japan
die nato partner sollen bei diesem
militärbündnis eigentlich auch eine
rolle spielen aber wie hätte man mit
magna darüber reden sollen wenn es ihnen
tatsächlich in erster linie auch um den
deal hätte gehen müssen also das ganze
ist ein signal glaube ich die europäer
dazu zu zwingen farbe zu bekennen wie
sie es halten mit china auch wenn die
heimlichtuerei die nato natürlich massiv
beschädigt dankeschön und daher gerade
in washington waren wenn man an die
letzten beiden wahlkämpfe in den usa
zurück denkt versteht man warum auch
us-zeitungen den wahlkampf in
deutschland boring finden wobei manche
dieser langeweile durchaus auch respekt
zollen wer in den jump jahren gelitten
hat und dann auch noch erleben musste
wie am ende die amerikanische demokratie
mit einem blutigen sturm aufs kapital
herausgefordert wurde für den sind
rielle zwischen olaf scholz armin
laschet und annalena baerbock geradezu
beneidenswert zivile veranstaltungen
scholz oder laschet einer von beiden
wird wohl ins kanzleramt einziehen für
beide geht es darum auf den letzten
metern jetzt nicht noch zu stolpern die
kandidaten heute auftraten hat simon
pfanzelt beobachtet
es könnte ja demnächst schwieriger
werden ein foto mit olaf scholz zu
bekommen und so sind es hunderte die ich
hier heute in münchen anstehen für ein
bild ein auto dran der kandidat arbeitet
das ab so wie er ja auch diese letzte
wahlkampfwoche noch abarbeiten muss ohne
viel aufregung und bloß keine fehler
machen in deutschland gibt es eine große
erwartung dass wir einen aufbruch
bekommen dass es losgeht nach dem 26
september mit den 20er jahren und das
ist eine gute zukunft für deutschland
wird scholz tut heute durch bayern
traditionell schwieriges gelände für
seine partei selbst hier in münchen
früher mal spd-hochburg hat die csu bei
der letzten bundestagswahl alle
direktmandate gewonnen doch scholz weckt
interesse auch wenn er viele menschen
nicht gerade begeistert er ist natürlich
kein kein sehr mitreißender redner aber
trotzdem ein guter und sachlicher mensch
und insgesamt sehr überzeugend in dem
was er sagt er ist der richtige mann
dass sich die situation ändern wird er
ist das geringere übel
das man mit ihm zumindest nichts falsch
macht diese stimmung soll scholz über
die ziellinie tragen armin laschet
bleibt noch eine woche und das zu
verhindern er ist heute in seinem
heimatbundesland unterwegs laschet
versucht in nordrhein westfalen den
eindruck zu zerstreuen dass die wahl
schon gelaufen sei geht es nicht um
lebensläufe oder wer wo wie quer gelacht
hat oder was auch immer es geht um die
politische richtung deutschlands in den
nächsten jahren und gast ist die
kernfrage
wir kämpfen die nächste bühne der
nächste versuch scholz auszubremsen die
durchsuchung im finanzministerium und
die ineffizienz der geldwäsche
spezialeinheit eu sollen dabei helfen
geldwäsche ist das geschäft
internationaler krimineller und wir
haben einen bundesfinanzminister dass er
auf sich ausübt und geld welche
unterbindet und wir erwarten dass das
restlos aufgeklärt wird warum das in
deutschland so schlecht funktionieren
holz macht es sich am nachmittag in
regensburg gemütlich aber er weiß auch
dass diese letzte woche ungemütlich
werden könnte am montag muss er in
sachen eu vor dem finanzausschuss des
bundestags
es ist einfach richtig festzuhalten was
gemacht worden ist und darüber gespräche
ich gerne wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
die it modernisiert wird wir haben dafür
sorge getragen dass jetzt künstliche
intelligenz eingesetzt werden kann wir
haben neue rechte beschafft
abfragemöglichkeiten bei den datenbanken
von polizei und staatsanwaltschaften wie
sie vorher nicht existiert haben
zuversicht ausstrahlen das wollen beide
kandidaten an diesem samstag die ganz
heiße phase des wahlkampfs läuft
von rückkehr zu normalität ist man in
den flutgebieten aartal noch weit
entfernt
und auch die bundestagswahl kann dort
diesmal nicht normal ablaufen viele
gebäude die früher als wahllokale
dienten wurden zerstört viele adressen
an die wahlunterlagen geschickt wurden
gibt es nicht mehr oder die empfänger
wohnen dort zumindest derzeit nicht
trotz dieser ausnahme situation muss
gesichert sein dass jeder und jede
wählen kann und dafür wurden auch
durchaus kreative lösungen gefunden wie
bobby cherry an beobachtet
zelt und bus kommen von der
landesforstverwaltung rheinland pfalz
die wahlhelferinnen und wahlhelfer von
der hochschule für öffentliche
verwaltung
bis kommenden freitag werden die
improvisierten wahl busse 120 stopps im
aartal wie hier in recht absolviert
haben so können menschen vor ort ihre
briefwahlunterlagen anfordern ausfüllen
und einwerfen gerade hier im aartal sind
die menschen aktuell notsituationen ihre
lebensbedingungen werden noch stärker
als in anderen situationen von der
politik beeinflusst und sofern glaube
ich ist es besonders wichtig dass die
menschen hier wahlrecht nutzen können
doch das ist gar nicht so einfach
klassische räumlichkeiten für wahllokale
wie turnhallen und schulen wurden durch
die flut im juli zerstört in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler soll am 26 september
unter anderem auf einem discounter
parkplatz gewählt werden auf die frage
welche bedeutung diese bundestagswahl
für die menschen überhaupt hat fällt das
echo in der stadt geteilt aus wir haben
ja andere probleme und kümmern uns
natürlich dass wir darum dass wir unsere
stadt wieder bestmöglich aufgebaut
bekommt wir beschäftigen uns sehr mit
der politik weil uns ja die politischen
entscheidungen jetzt sehr sehr sehr
betreffen und deswegen dadurch
beschäftigen wir uns halt mit der
politischen frage und damit auch mit der
wahl für die menschen konnte es glaube
ich jetzt drauf an welche politiker sich
am meisten um sie kümmern im flutgebiet
gibt es weder wahlplakate noch
kundgebungen darauf haben sich die
parteien in rheinland pfalz gemeinsam
verständigt auch beim anteil radio einer
der vielen freiwilligen initiativen ist
klar wahlwerbespots nein infos zur wahl
auf jeden fall das ist ja eine besondere
war dadurch dass sich die frage stellt
wie wählt man überhaupt wo kann man
welche stimme abgeben da machen wir
relativ viel im vorfeld aber aktiv
werbung machen wir nicht dass wir in der
situation auch mehr als unangepasst die
politik müsse auf andere art und weise
präsent sein und interesse zeigen am
schicksal der menschen so der erste
beigeordnete des landkreises ahrweiler
es waren ja auch viele der
politikerinnen und politiker im
flutgebiet unterwegs und haben auf diese
art und weise auch die kommunikation mit
den wählerinnen und wählern gesucht mit
den betroffenen hier fordern ich glaube
das ist ja auch die aufgabe letztendlich
der politik vor ort zu sein bei den
menschen zuzuhören und vor allem mit
anzupacken
landes und bundes wahlleitung erwarten
eine normale wahlbeteiligung im
flutgebiet über die zusätzlichen kosten
für zelte und busse mache man sich keine
großen gedanken ohne aufwand ist
demokratie nun einmal nicht zu haben
und jetzt gibt es andere nachrichten des
tages von heinz wolf in der diskussion
über das weitere vorgehen in der korona
pandemie plädiert der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
gassen für ein ende der beschränkungen
zum 30 oktober damit solle auch ein impf
anreiz gesetzt werden sich bis dahin
immunisieren zu lassen so gassen andere
experten warnen vor zu schnellen
lockerungen und so sind die aktuellen
corona zahlen das robert koch institut
meldet
8901 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 2313 weniger als am
vergangenen samstag 63 todesfälle kamen
innerhalb eines tages hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei
72,0
zwei wochen vor dem jahrestag der
deutschen einheit am 3 oktober hat in
halle an der saale die
freiluftausstellung einheits expo
begonnen sachsen-anhalts regierungschef
und bundesratspräsident reiner haseloff
und vertreter der stadt eröffneten den
rund 4,5 kilometer langen rundgang wegen
der korona pandemie gibt es wie schon im
vergangenen jahr kein bürgerfest mit
hunderttausenden besuchern sondern
stadtweite präsentationen über einen
längeren zeitraum
in leipzig ist es im zuge einer
demonstration zu ausschreitungen
gekommen an der kundgebung die von einem
kampagnenbündnis organisiert wurde
beteiligten sich laut polizei bis zu
3500 menschen anlass war der prozess
gegen eine frau und drei männer denen
die bundesanwaltschaft mitgliedschaft in
einer kriminellen vereinigung und
angriffe auf mutmaßliche rechte vorwirft
während des aufzugs gab es immer wieder
unter anderem steinwürfe später
entzündeten vermummte barrikaden die
polizei fuhr wasserwerfer auf die mit
steinen beworfen wurden wie die polizei
am abend mitteilte wurden sieben beamte
leicht verletzt
rund um eine grenzbrücke zwischen mexiko
und texas harren derzeit mehr als 10.000
flüchtlinge aus in der hoffnung in den
usa asyl zu bekommen der großteil von
ihnen stammt aus haiti die
versorgungslage ist katastrophal und die
behörden rechnen mit tausenden weiteren
bekannten die betroffene gemeinde der
rio hat hilfe aus washington angefordert
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
69 21
34 36 49 superzahl 2 beiträge win zahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und in
zdf text auf seite 55 7 bleiben noch die
wetteraussichten für den sonntag teils
ist es aufgelockert teils stärker
bewölkt im südwesten und am alpenrand
zieht regen auf die höchstwerte
erreichen 14 bis 22 grad die weiteren
aussichten am montag wechseln bei 14 bis
20 grad sonne und wolken im süden kann
es etwas regnen dienstag und mittwoch
gibt es meist freundliches wetter bei
ähnlichen temperaturen
das was von uns weiter geht's mit dem
aktuellen sportstudio und danach um 0.55
gibt es dann die nächste heute express
bis morgen habe jeder sehr wieder sind
[Musik]